yo where we go grab Master Reaper man
got a now that's no no name in there
Klaus Arriba man that's not this name
okay we get a bank oh no something
similar only a six yeah let's just go a
four that's a funny way to play getting
into a snake Ben Oni with those moves
inserted I came just plain normal
development moves him nothing fancy sure
yeah okay looks a lot like it runs into
e4 at some point so I can start with
this I can always play you form maybe
Bishop f4 was an idea actually
mmm we can playing that Bishop f4 to
simply look at to look at the d6 pawn
hmm don't really get any of that you
this this opening is puzzling me am I
not just pushing stuff for with you so
f4 what is happening night she's sick so
what okay let's just do this
just looks like I have a big Center
there and he has a very weird pieces so
hmm Bishop f3 Bishop d3 I don't know
maybe here not quite sure about it okay
is angling for b5 and probably will
manage to play b5
okay let's do this
yeah I was thinking before might be a
move I'm not true about this it's a bit
bit of a tricky tricky move by talking
it it looks it looks white blocking this
thing getting the pawn back here anyway
check you know night before possibly
knight c6 I really my my doubts here
yeah I was thinking I still get it back
rook b1 or what Queenie five maybe
tonight b3 I also have and also and this
is a good let's do that he for is
covered and I have five as a possible
threat and night D 496 it's quite a bit
Queen d2 night X before it's also very
serious it's something he has to do
something really drastic now that kills
my Center or I don't know something
something something big
otherwise he just gets gets completely
stoned to the ground okay so ii five
maybe cannot even take a Seaford hangs
and he's six
okay so f5 this is what I meant with
stomped to the ground
maybe I'm overestimating it but it looks
it looks quite bad so night see five he
would take on f5 I guess but okay let's
let's take first to know he would not he
does not take there so d6 96 95 I can
take a nade I don't know let's play that
first it's right anyway okay sticking
there let's see I can just take a two
now let's take a two and check now how
to play that d7 is winning I guess it
does d7
yeah I think it wins okay hey de esta is
the point
well it does he have some way out here
like in 97 or something I don't think so
there's also a very weak back rank with
the night I with the bishop on h7
no don't see any move here routine it
today I'm just promoting those points
this is the pin this is the jack bad
side of the Benoni ax those pawns D 796
that's a Benoni nightmare be nice to get
reason to get his 7 but he didn't let me
yeah I'm back over 2500 again with a
nice series of wins some lucky some some
nice I've thought one of the the nicer
ones yeah well this this kind of setup
looks really weird yeah I'm putting the
bishop there in the night on g6 I have a
hard time to believe that this is any
good I mean what has Center and what
does black have besides the traffic jam
on the kingside so this this yeah before
I think interesting a computer is not
giving that move it wants to play b3
yeah well this is actually also pretty
good yeah that's a good prophylactic
move the idea is that before is quite
bad yeah I'm getting here or possibly
this night over that's that's really bad
b3 is a pretty good move but this was
interesting what is the computer giving
it wants to play h5 now that's a
difficult move to play for a human
player
it's interesting the idea is that after
possible h4 my bishop is forced to move
and f forward drop computer gives this
quite crazy line this and this Knight
iegs and then he fire
quite funny 93 he takes f6 91 assessment
is equal yeah crazy
yes something like that is truly what
she has to try age five yeah here I
don't know that that looked looked
really nice now and 85 and I compass on
0.6 0.7 evaluations like that so it's
not like winning but it's it's
definitely very difficult to play for
black you find yeah after that it gives
white a win or a very good position yeah
II six f5 I really thought he has to I
don't know
I don't know what I thought what he has
to do but if he is he doesn't have
anything it seems so according to the
engine and this means those pawns are
simply bulldozing him yeah look at us
look III is given by the computer as
tougher yeah that is tough ayah because
if I take the knight
this is still a kind of tricky look to
eat a threaten so probably has to take
and then this then it's still very
difficult to play I mean even though the
engine is very optimistic this this
would have been very difficult to play
yeah this is was good news
yeah yeah I'm I'm totally winning Jack
it would have been nice to get in he
seven but it didn't he didn't allow that
okay well thanks for watching